what ruins the story for you
in authenticity is that how you say that
yeah when
when you know that it's not authentic
that is what really just
ruins uh a film or a story for me when
you know this
is not the exact example of what this
person would have done
felt or truly believed i think it just
takes it always just seems to take me
out of the piece that's when i
when i when i see it's not authentic is
it the acting or is it the writing how
the character is portrayed
i think it's a little bit of both um at
times
i recently saw a play on broadway where
a woman was dealing with a very
hard situation as far as her son and
trying to figure out where he was and
how he was
but i could also tell that the story
wasn't
authentically written it didn't come
from an authentic place
i think the actors did a phenomenal job
with the material that she was given but
i feel
like they were trying to tell a story as
opposed to letting the story come from
within
i think all of us get stories all the
time and we want to go out and just tell
those different stories but i think the
ones
that resonate the most they come from a
place
of authenticity not saying it
necessarily has to be your story
but it has to just be authentic and if
it's authentic people will connect with
that
right there's always i mean especially
now there's a debate on
can someone really tell a story about
struggle or whatever
if they haven't really lived it yeah you
know especially if they've lived a total
opposite
right right but the reality because i
kind of faced that with a recent project
that i had done where i didn't i wasn't
i didn't have the same experience as the
protagonist
of the series so i was kind of
challenged on it in some ways
but there is a such thing as a human
experience
right and once you're able to find that
human experience
um everybody's dealing with the same
things we're all dealing with loss we're
all dealing with grief we're all dealing
with joy we're all dealing with love and
we're all dealing with it in varying
ways and so the difference between
something being
inauthentic and um
not well purposed which that happens
where people try to
tell a story that they're not doing it
is it they come from a very human place
but if you come from a human place
people will always be able to
see the authenticity waves is a great
example of that the filmmaker
is white but the story is black but it
resonates
the last black man in san francisco the
filmmaker is white the protagonist is
black
but it relates because it's an authentic
human story that anybody can buy into
and believe in
yeah i really love that movie i hope it
gets nominated
yeah i hope it does too i really i think
it was a special
piece of theater i hadn't cried in the
theater in such a long time
but just to know because i've had that
experience of like a friendship that
jess has run its course and to see their
friendship fall the way that
it was just beautifully executed the
cinematographer was amazing
right and they both um you know the one
character
had more of a stable home life and they
you know they tried to kind of take him
in
but i think he knew like i don't really
belong here
yeah and i know you're trying to make it
feel like i belong here but i don't i
don't belong here
and so it was about place it was about
belonging
and um i don't want to give it away for
anybody who hasn't seen it but um
yeah it's really beautiful film it was
an exciting piece of work yeah
it really was i hope i hope it gets some
kind of
recognition yeah something me too you
know it's hard when a lot of stories
like that just kind of just
get shelved and
yeah that's why we need independent
cinema you know it's
when i go to do you go to a lot of
independent theaters oh i still do all
the time
still do i'm still committed to that
process because that's where i am i'm an
independent i'm an indie
filmmaker i'm not in the studio system
and in a lot of ways
while i regard it greatly i'm not sure
that that's where i'm supposed to be
just yet i'm supposed to be in the
studio system because the independent
system makes the most sense to me
i love having control over my stories
and my ideas
and to be able to accomplish those ideas
in the most authentic way possible
right and i think for i for me i don't
know maybe for you too but those are the
stories that resonate with me the most
yep
are those indie stories not the studio
ones where
no one claps when they get up and they
and okay
you know time to go to grandma's house
now or where yeah i mean you know i'm
just saying like it's it's just a pit
stop in between where i think people
that go to independent cinema
it's to really feel something just
experience it be affected by it
absolutely and to have a conversation
with a total stranger afterwards
absolutely that you wouldn't normally
talk to absolutely
that's absolutely the case absolutely
right and i hope
i hope that doesn't go away because i
know those theaters are in danger
sometimes because there's not enough
money behind them